the gyro can experience but yeah it was
dope is [ __ ] man like just being out
there I take I took a lot of pictures
and [ __ ]
I got it like a histogram paid why I
used to post post dope pics from when I
traveled and [ __ ] did they make you take
malaria medication
I never took nothing it know where I
went really uh and I'm glad I didn't cuz
I heard people that do take them shots
and stuff they get sick real circuit
yeah yeah well thank you and plus I
don't eat a lot so it ain't too much
that's gonna [ __ ] me up I eat McDonald's
wherever I go McDonald's is your friend
are you out the country it's thank you
see is that the shot up there oh the
show take that one too yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah I took that pit so is this your
other Instagram the comedic guy
yeah that's my other other so it's just
photographs photographs like just and I
call the comedic guy cuz I think
comedians got the best that you know cuz
we observe you know so I mean you should
be able to take good pics if your
comedian well this meat markets intense
whereas that was it a Zanzibar whoa I
think what kind of meat is on that oh
[ __ ] I don't know something I even eat
don't eat McDonald's man like I don't
trust me and matter of fact me in our a
drew one time we went to uh we did the
hip not the Hip Hop Awards [ __ ] the MTV
Awards over in Europe and why we was
over there the crew and everything and I
I travelled alive I'm like man I was
like man we gonna go get something to
eat and I'm like I ain't eating this
[ __ ] like not come on let's go get
something I was like man you gonna [ __ ]
up go over there everybody the whole
crew had to go to the hospital I was the
only girl really here cuz I don't eat
that [ __ ] food y'all got food poison
trying to eat Andrew - I'm not sure he
said he didn't but I swear I told him -
he said he didn't get it but he might
have listened to me that time but but
for the most part I just don't eat when
I go out to country I eat [ __ ] that I'm
used to fruit rice it's chicken and
McDonald's McDonald's you ever see one
of those cheeseburgers or they put it on
a shelf for a year and they film it a
year to see if it deteriorates here
later it looks like
caput there that's a good thing though
right baby
that's like space food like that space
food like if space food is good for the
Austral astronauts yeah it gotta be good
for us like we be hating on McDonald's
way too much like nobody's really really
died on on paper right they have from
jacket they dad from eating a lot you
eat anything a lot you going guys PP he
fishing and fat is [ __ ] that's true but
I think someone's died from e.coli I
think that was a bird that was
jack-in-the-box oh right they had an
e.coli outbreak I mean but that could be
at everything and it could be in any
restaurant a place that [ __ ] that you
just showed on there I'm pretty sure as
Ecoline that [ __ ] oh yeah they buy the
immune to it yeah that's what they learn
to from traveling at the end of the day
you can eat anything you just can't eat
a lot of it
[Applause]